هالاند خارج الملعب مزارع يغني الراب
هناك معلومات يعرفها الجميع عن مهاجم
مانشستر سيتي ايرلينغ هالاند هداف وفتاك
وخارق امام الشباك ولكن هناك اشياء قد لا
يعرفها كثيرون بعضها يشبه شخصيته المتعارف
عليها والبعض الاخر يبدو غريبا للغايه
مثلا ان المهاجم النرويجي يحمل الرقم
القياسي العالمي لاطول قفزه طويله صامده
لطفل في الخامسه من عمره تلك التي سجلها
في يناير من العام 2006 والتي تبلغ مترا و
63 سم في طفولته كان ايضا يضع نشيد دوري
ابطال اوروبا كمنبه صباحي يستيقظ عليه
ربما يفسر ذلك سر ارقامه العجيبه في
البطوله ولعه بالتهديف بدا مبكرا ايضا حيث
يمتلك رقما قياسيا بتسجيل تسعه اهداف في
مباراه واحده بكاس العالم تحت 20 عاما
نسخه العام 2019 في مباراه فازت بها بلاده
النرويج على الهندوراس باثنا عشر هدفا لا
شيء
تواجده مع ريد بول سالزبورغ لم يكن هالاند
يستطيع النوم سوى بجوار كرات الهاتريك
التي حصل عليها وقد برر ذلك بانه يشعر
بالراحه حين يحتضنهم قبل ان ينام كلاعب
صاعد لم يكن ملهمه لكريستيانو رونالدو ولا
ليونيل ميسي ونزلتان ابراهيموفيتش وانما
بيتشوب مهاجم سوانزي سيتي وقتها الذي قدم
موسم عمره في 2013 وقاد سوانزي للقب كاس
الرابطه ابان طفوله ايرلينج الذي تابع ذلك
بكل اهتمام
مواهب هالاند لا تتوقف عند كره القدم فقط
بل انه كان جزءا من مجموعه الراب المسماه
فولو كينجز جنبا الى جنب مع اللاعبين
النرويجيين الشباب
ايريكتوبيا
وقد حكى ايرلينج عن هذه التجربه قائلا
انها كانت للتسليه في وقت فراغهم اثناء
معسكرات منتخب الشباب
يحب الحيوانات ورعايتها ويحلم بعد
الاعتزال باقتناء مزرعه صغيره يعيش فيها
حياه الريفيه متاثرا بنشاته في مدينه بيرن
التي يقطنها مزارعون صغيرون وتقع على بعد
25 ميلا جنوب
لديه ايضا مشروب مفضل وعلى ما يبدو هو
السبب في تلك الطاقه التي يتمتع بها وهو
خليط من اللبن واللفت والسبانخ ايضا
مواطنه جوش و كينج كشف عن عادات غريبه له
تتعلق بالطعام قائلا لم ارى شخصا ياكل
كثيرا كما يفعل هالاند انه ياكل مثل الدب
لكنه لا يزال واحدا من الطف الاشخاص الذين
يمكنك مقابلتهم وربما يفسر ذلك زياده حجم
عضلاته بصوره كبيره مؤخرا المهاجم
النرويجي خطف انظار العالم منذ تالقه في
ريد بولز ويبدو انه سيستمر في ذلك لسنوات
قادمه وستستمر معه الجماهير في الانبهار
بما يقدمه داخل الملعب وكذلك بحكايته
الغريبه التي تكتشف عنه يوما بعد يوم فيما
يتعلق بحياته الخاصه خارج المستطيل الاخضر